This number of words you know
is sort of, uh, an indication of
your potential in the language.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here
today, and today, I'm going to talk
about something very important in
language learning, maybe in some
ways the most important thing: words.
How Do we learn them?
Why are they important?
How do we use them?
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
I do appreciate it.
So when I started with my son Mark into
LingQ and I was doing a lot of thinking
about language learning, in fact, I did a
lot of research, uh, read books in English
and Swedish and German in French on this
whole subject of language learning, I
came to the conclusion that the single
most, I called it, the Gordian knot....
The single simplest sort of
evaluation of where we are in a
language is how many words we know.
All right.
Get a lot of criticism, people say, no,
you can be fluent with a few words, but
in fact, you can't and I'll explain why.
And so before I get going, though,
I want to show you that I don't just
sort of rely on my own experience.
Although obviously, anybody talking
about say language learning is going
to refer to their own experience.
But I also did a lot of
research and I had a look...
you'll see behind me I
have all these books.
I have CDs that I've listened to, but
I went and looked at my bookshelf here.
So here's one of the books Learning
Vocabulary in Another Language ISP Nation.
All right.
I have lots of books on...
second language acquisition.
Rod Ellis, he does talk
about vocabulary acquisition.
Second Language Vocabulary Acquisition.
Norbert Schmitt, Vocabulary
in Language Teaching.
And what have we got here?
Again Norbert Schmitt.
Uh, this is from Cambridge
Description, Acquisition and Pedagogy.
So it's not as if I haven't looked.
I found that most of these books
were unnecessarily complicated.
Again, I, I tend to look
for the Occam's raz...
Occam's razor.
In other words, the simplest explanation
of a phenomenon, the Gordian knot.
And to me, words are the key sort
of measure of where we are in
our language and how we acquire
them actually is quite simple.
Um, there's a lot of talk about, you
know, you must read content that only
has a small percentage of new words
in it, or that you have to meet a word
so many times before you'll learn it.
And all of that is almost irrelevant.
To me learning words again, you'll not
be surprised to hear me say this is
all about acquiring them naturally.
It's not because you say, I want
to learn 5,000 words that you're
going to learn 5,000 words.
It's not because you deliberately
sit there with a stash of, of, uh,
cards flashcards, or because you
read the dictionary that you're
going to acquire all those words.
It may be something you enjoyed doing.
It is a form of exposure to those
words, but ultimately it's going to
be the amount that you are exposed
to the language in a meaningful
environment that is pleasant to you.
That is conducive to the brain
gradually acquiring these words.
That's going to do it.
It's a bit like if you go up to a girl
or if you're a girl, you go up to a guy
or whatever you go and say I want to
be your girlfriend or your boyfriend.
That's not going to do it.
You actually have to, it's
more indirect than that.
You can't just say, I want
to acquire all these words.
What happens is you're acquiring
them in the background.
All right.
And that's why when we created
LingQ, we wanted to have a measure
of the words you're learning.
And I will show you a snapshot of all
the different languages that I have
learned on LingQ and how many words
I know in each of those languages.
And that is a statistic
that's quite encouraging, but
it's not an absolute number.
Um, I may know words in language, more
words in a certain language and in another
language, but because I'm working on, uh,
Persian right now, I can speak it better
than Czech erhaps, although I know far
more words in Czech than I do in Persian.
Uh, if I were to go back to
Czech, I would quickly recover it.
So that this number of words, you
know, is sort of, uh, an indication
of your potential in the language.
It's also relative.
So in some languages like the
Slavic languages, there are many
forms of essentially the same word.
That means that the word count the way
we count them at LingQ where we count
each form of the word as a different
word, that word count is going to
be a bit bloated compared to other
languages where that's not the case.
So it's not an absolute
number, but it's an indication.
It's an indication that
you're making progress.
You know, say six months
ago I knew 5,000 words.
Now I know 20,000 words.
So those moments when I feel I'm
not progressing in the language,
the plateau, the doldrums.
It reminds me that in fact, you
have acquired a lot of words.
Now, some people say, what
does it mean to know a word?
All right.
Uh, you can't claim to know word
unless you can use it say some people.
I don't agree with that.
I am very much a proponent of
acquiring a large passive vocabulary.
And if you understand a word in at
least one context, you know that
word, at least for that context.
If you come across it again, and it
doesn't make sense in that context
and you look it up again and you
find that there's another scope
of meaning for that word, fine.
But passive vocabulary is what
it's all about because passive
vocabulary is the door to reading in
the language, understanding movies
in the language, having meaningful
conversations in the language.
All of which opens you up to
meaningful, compelling input.
Without the passive vocabulary,
you can't do those things.
So I have always been against the
idea of trying to make sure that you
can use every word you learn, go to
conversation class, try to use it.
If I have an opportunity to use
whatever little I've learned
in the language, I will do so.
And typically, even at a relatively low
vocabulary level, I may start having
sessions once or twice a week with a tutor
because it kind of helps me a little bit.
It tends to make my input activities more
interesting for me, but fundamentally
I rely on increasing my word count my
passive vocabulary because that's what's
going to enable me to learn the language.
And if we acquire these words in what
I would call an honest way, which means
through massive listening and reading, we
are not only acquiring the words we are
acquiring familiarity with the language.
Because again, it's a bit like the I've
often referred to sort of a dog races
where the dogs chase a mechanical rabbit.
If we are trying to increase
our vocabulary, that drags
us through all this content.
And as we are listening and reading
our brain is becoming more and
more familiar with the language,
increasing our comprehension level,
increasing our passive vocabulary so
that we can then do more things in
the language, including engage with
people in meaningful conversa...
conversation.
That's not to say that I
don't occasionally, you
know, uh, do the flashcards.
Predominantly phrases, by the way.
I very much recommend doing flashcards
for phrases rather than individual words.
I will sometimes pick up interesting
dictionaries, for example, you
know, I like this, uh, you know...
so I can see German and Russian
side-by-side, it's just fun to do that.
I don't know what it's doing
for me, but it's fun to do that.
Similarly.
I have one here for Portuguese.
So I can see Portuguese and German
side by side, which is fun and
expands my sense of the language.
Similar to here we have a...
so I can see Russian
and Czech side by side.
These are fun things to do.
There's nothing wrong with doing
them, but fundamentally the
words are acquired through input.
And, uh, as we acquire these words,
we are acquiring the language.
And so if your word count at LingQ
is now up to 10,000, 20,000, 30,000,
it's not necessarily something that
you can brag to other people about,
but it is an indication that you
are progressing in the language.
Now I did make some notes here,
but I'm not going to worry about.
Uh, I had a few other things that I
wanted to say, but I can't remember
them, but I just want to leave you
with that thought that work on your
vocabulary, work on words and phrases.
Uh, if you have more opportunity to
speak and if you speak more, you'll
speak better, more fluently, but
you have to have that basis in the
language, which comes from having a
large passive vocabulary because the
native speakers that you will encounter,
uh, either face-to-face individually
or with a group or in movies or books
or podcasts, they all have in almost
every case, a larger passive vocabulary
in your target language than you do.
And to understand them and
interact with them and, and
benefit from interacting with them.
You need that large passive vocabulary.
So there you have it, words.
How we acquire words.
It still comes back to
that basic massive input.
Good luck.
And I will leave you a couple
of videos that I have done
previously on the same subject.
Hopefully I don't contradict myself.
Bye for now.